i want to jump to some current events
from today and talk about the
ramifications of this control and these
oligarchs and where we're currently at
because it's a hard segue into more
political stuff but i think all of this
is tied together in the culture war from
timcast.com court rules anyone charged
as an insurrectionist can be barred from
political office the decision comes
after north carolina voters challenged
madison thorn's re-election bid to put
it simply
we thought that this was crushed because
democrats are basically trying to make
it so that people like marjorie taylor
green madison cawthorne cannot run for
re-election
what ends up happening is the court says
because of this clemency act or whatever
in 1872 you can't use this against
people anymore now a federal court says
federal court says now actually you can
so one of the things we end up seeing
from all of this manipulation and
control on social media they're trying
to craft the narrative they've been
trying as hard as possible before free
you know an open internet
before we all were our culture developed
on on the internet
the big uh networks controlled
everything if they said it it was true
and that's power
the media has been desperately trying to
claim that all of these republicans are
insurrectionists simply because they
voted not to certify election results
because they wanted an investigation or
who knows why they did it you also had i
think half the states in a lawsuit
against the other half of the states at
one point with texas leading the charge
taking issue with how the election was
handled in 2020. now they're trying to
argue that that
everything that uh happened was an
insurrection and therefore 147
republicans can be barred from office i
i gotta say just the fact that there is
a vote to
to verify the election results means
that you can vote yes or no they they
have a vote on purpose so it doesn't
matter how you vote on that well this is
this is the crazy thing that i think we
see with everything
why is it that
they they don't want free speech because
they don't want a fair playing field
they don't want to have to deal with
proving themselves right why are they
going after the this this 14th amendment
thing because they're going to lose they
know they're going to lose
we are we are dealing with an
establishment it's it's it's the big
tech companies the media companies the
democratic party many republicans as
well they're part of the establishment
and their goal is just to maintain
control and power by any means necessary
is this true that so it's just being
charged with this it's not even being
convicted it's just being charged can
bar someone even if they're found
innocent well being charged for
insurrection is is nebulous
it's what does that mean
i don't know the media the media said
the media has repeatedly said
definitively that certain people have
committed insurrection they're just
they're just outright saying it and
that's why they tried arguing
they they tried suing saying no medicine
hawthorne can't run because by speaking
this event he engaged in insurrection
man i'm using brave and i'm using the
brave search brave browser research i
just typed in insurrection to get a
definition the on the right 2021 united
states capital attack attack comes up it
says attack like this is mass media
manipulation in my face and it's brave
just insurrection and they just assume
that i'm i know well i mean i suppose
you can say some people a lot of people
there did attack you know i guess i mean
that's propaganda right you say attack
on one side and you say protest on the
other side
yup and whoever controls the narrative
is going to control the outcome
and taken to it it's logical conclusion
you wind up with one of the constitution
the sovereign constitutional branches of
government democratic branches of
government uh having its sovereignty uh
replaced with with that of another
whatever you want to call this other uh
media branch or whoever whoever is going
to decide um what is an insurrection in
the public eye uh they are able to
decide when um what we would take is the
the unlimited sovereignty of congress to
vote how it will be to impose its will
on the other two branches as laid out in
the constitution comes to an end and i
mean
that's scary this is why our ability to
speak freely in the public is so
important for the longest time
you spoke in the public or i mean
actually as long as people go to
churches and they would talk to each
other you also had physical events but
you did have media controlling a large
share of what people thought was true
and they just blindly believed it
now with the internet
they're trying to lock down i think they
were surprised by 2016 they didn't
realize how powerful the internet was
going to be that
people basically memed trump into the
presidency they have to stop it so they
go after alex jones they go after you
know milo they go after laura loomer all
of these people who are on the right who
are allowed and generating tons of
attention
all of a sudden we see one day
alex jones gets purged from basically
every single from from app stores from
podcasts from every social platform
there's no way that wasn't coordinated
you can see the coordination too when
one network will ban it and then within
like a week another network bans it you
could just be say that like maybe
facebook watched twitter ban them and
was like we're gonna follow suit but i
got a feeling i mean you were in silicon
valley you'd know better than anyone i
actually think it was more than just
kind of like this group thing and like
with alex alex jones is probably the
best example of this where like within a
day like he was removed from three or
four platforms yeah i feel like there
was just so much so many people whining
to get rid of alex jones at those
companies as soon as one of them
actually like like dove into the pool
they all just kind of followed
automatically afterwards
so i don't i i guess maybe i'm a bit of
a skeptic on like that they had like a a
board room meeting where they all
decided now is when we ban alex jones
it's just my group like if they had like
a meeting in like davos switzerland or
something to decide all this stuff
that'd be crazy i think it's the middle
ground
i don't think that they all had you know
they pressed a button to go to the sub
basement where all of the big tech
buildings meet and they sit in the
council chamber with torches or anything
like that i think
they went out to lunch
and they were like
what are you what are you guys doing
over at twitter about this alex jones
thing and they're like well we don't
know exactly what you guys over at
facebook doing what were we thinking
about banning them and then you know a
handful of guys who were from different
departments were talking they went back
and said that's what they're gonna do
and so then when one person did okay and
then everyone does it because they walk
in lockstep with each other yeah they're
probably probably like one of them one
of them texts their friend over in the
same department at a other company and
says we finally got rid of alex jones
and then they text their friends at the
you know new york times the washington
post as well they say this is what we're
going to do and then those people get in
touch with the pr department of the tech
company that hasn't done taken the same
action it says did you know you know we
that these other platforms are going to
ban them what are you doing are you
going to allow this to continue on yours
exclusively yup and the nail that sticks
out gets hammered and they know that i
uh
if there is one one profession that i i
would say i despise more than anything
it's probably journalists
because like the actual real profession
is is honorable noble and important
that's not what we have today in any any
sense of the imagination i mean you got
a handful you've got you know maybe a
handful of people over at breitbart alan
bakari for instance friend of ours who's
done great reporting on the tech
censorship stuff you've got good
journalists who really do work at a lot
of mainstream corporate press that's a
fact like local outlets especially
they do they do their job a lot of
reporting is like you know the local
fire department is being shut down for
renovations and they're telling their
local community all that's fantastic but
we have at the highest level
exactly what you just described where a
journalist
will reach out and say hi i'm calling
from the new york times and i'm just
wondering why you support white
supremacy by allowing alex jones on your
platform we're going to write that you
are klansmen by the way and then the
company freaks out and they're like no
no no no no we'll bam we'll ban him
please leave us alone please don't wield
the power of your you know millions of
views or whatever against us i wonder if
it's more uh more coordinated because
i'm looking at who owns meta which is
facebook's parent company well vanguard
blackrock state street those are the
three of the top four there's also
fidelity management who owns alphabet
the parent company of google vanguard
blackrock state street yeah uh so is it
the the corporate ceos of these comp are
there even ceos because these companies
own each other when you start to look
into it you're like who runs what like
is it just 20 dudes sitting in their
mountain base like okay now we're making
like do they decide facebook's going to
ban alex jones or was that mark who
makes that decision these guys own 20 of
the company these these three these
three corporations own almost 20 percent
of these companies both of them
and it's just a question that maybe
can't be answered because that's they've
opticated it on purpose
yeah i don't know the answer to that um
it's potential there's a lot more
collusion coming from the top up uh
you know i would say this that you know
the ceos
of these companies do have to be good to
be successful so they they have a fair
amount of independence
good that's interesting word good well
effective they have to be good managers
they have to be able to juggle a lot of
balls um
i mean if you look at what bill gates is
funding
there's coordination
not in the sense maybe where these
companies
like i said you know go to the
sub-basement have a cabal meet or
anything like that
but
it's not as complicated as people might
think it is when they say oh you're
believing conspiracies oh that's
nonsense no no look a rich dude hires
people who do does the things that he
likes
so
i mean look fudo wants to hire
programmers to you know get out of
silicon valley bill gates wants to hire
people and give access to resources who
don't believe in free speech and want to
reduce the population
so reduce population growth to be more
specific so he's going to hire people
who are powerfully advocating for these
things and empower what he wants and
he's got the resources to do it so then
he gives money to a bunch of different
groups all of those groups agree all of
those groups join forces and now you've
got this coordinated massive wave of
companies many of them focusing in
different areas but now they're
coalescing around one thing elon musk
bad
there's a coordination be it on accident
or otherwise
yeah and you guys seem to have figured
out that bitching about it isn't the
answer you got to create parallel system
with fudo
um yeah base i mean i wouldn't say a
parallel system certainly i would like
for futo to be a
one of the things about google that is
really nice is just you have so many
smart engineers around you who kind of
know how various things work we would
love for futo to develop into that kind
of organization where you you can
actually quit google and not just be
isolated by yourself
without
without kind of any of that knowledge to
feed off of in your work tell me an
example of like if a developer came to
futo and they started getting involved
what would it be like for them
um well
ideally they would like
say you needed to know how to do some
gpu programming that's very very obscure
and right now only a few people who work
on like low-level android code or who
work at you know qualcomm
know
like there would actually be somebody at
futo that like we would we would have
that they could talk to and like get
that information about how to program
their computer you guys should talk to
james o'keefe okay
yeah
and then when all the whistleblowers
commented and just be like right this
way gentlemen here's some jobs would
they like re-um relocate to texas or
would they be able to work remote both
both whatever they yeah it can be
virtual and in person where our
headquarters are in texas so are you
hiring because i know you mentioned
before the show it's kind of like a y
combinator style like um like what those
called like incubator incubators we got
we have a couple of different
initiatives on first we are trying to
hire full-time engineers we have we are
first and foremost an engineering firm
we have a couple of projects underway
in-house and we'd like to have more
that's sort of we're doing some regular
hiring like that we're also doing a y
combinator style if you will grant
program this summer in austin texas it's
residential we're going to have a cool
house to stay in incubator space lots of
support
we're going to select three teams of up
to five engineers twenty thousand
dollars for each team member no strings
attached we don't want equity we just
want people working on cool stuff that
creates viable tech alternatives thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm we'll see
you all there